I guess the first thing I kind of wanted
to ask was I want you to tell me a
little bit about yours yeah so I work in
social media and I've done that for
about a year and a half before that I
worked in sales and in sales I sold
copiers okay so yeah you have a
marketing background a social media
background yeah so I kind of asked why
did you apply for this position why is
you know our cause or our mission
important to you yeah the body because
it was body positive right yeah so I was
thinking body positive the best way we
could be body positive was to help
people lose weight so I'm a personal
trainer I'm certified so I was like I
could really help people lose weight yes
uh